on soir virginie joron merci d'être avec
nous alors pour bien comprendre qu est
ce qu on vous reproche exactement pour
que votre nom atterrissent avec d'autres
sur une liste noire c'est une forme de
sanction politique selon vous j'aimerais
bien savoir ce qu'on me reproche est
effectivement il ya un an effectivement
nous sommes déplacés en russie en prix
mais moi j'ai appris que j'étais sur une
fiche
enfin j'étais fiche est plutôt que
d'être sanctionné lundi donc j'ai pas
été auditionnés j'ai pas été alerté du
fait que je sois allé l'année dernière
en crimée pour effectivement observé au
titre de mon mandat de député
parlementaire d'une élection qui se
déroulait dans l'état de en russie et en
prime et donc voilà donc je découvre
cette liste noire avec vous depuis lundi
je vois qu'il ya pas mal de
désinformation autour de ce fait qui est
un fait avéré est aussi transparente
puisque moi j'ai aimé le collègue
nous avons déclaré de cette mission
auprès du parlement et la voilà
peut-être le timing est presque parce
que bon mais un peu trop tard parce que
les élections sont passées on nous sort
ce dossier pour faire du bruit pour nous
c'est à dire nous ne sommes pas dû c'est
une sanction entre guillemets politique
parce que moi je considère que mon
mandat de parlementaire me permet
d'aller là où j'ai envie d'aller
je vous rappelle que les traités nous
permettent d'aller où on veut la libre
circulation en soi et voilà je pense que
c'est une communication de la part d'un
groupuscule qui oscille pas
permettez-moi de lierre jusqu'à
aujourd'hui après deux ans de mandat je
n'avais pas connaissance de cette
délégation
alors peut-être qu'ils sont jaloux du
fait que nous souhaitons aller là bas
voir ce qu'il s'est passé si eux ne
souhaitent pas y aller
et bien moi je considère une élection et
peut aussi être vu par d'autres députés
et
à ce jour effectivement je m'interroge
sur le fondement de cette soi-disante
liste noire et sanctions voilà il faut
se poser des questions pourquoi ça tombe
maintenant pour qui c'est
ce sont ces sanctions
et c'est quoi le but parce que d'autres
députés et aussi par une telle mission
on a bien vu au venezuela une députée de
la france insoumise ou encore un autre
membre du parti au kazakhstan et au par
contre on peut être s'en tient donc
encore une fois voilà on veut mettre le
zoom sur sur new bond je trouve que
voilà c'est assez injuste
ça tombe un peu peut-être presque pour
eux mal parce que les élections se sont
passées
mais sur le fond voilà c'est plutôt une
question politique
on voit bien le parlement dès qu'ils
peuvent être anti russe entre guillemets
ou sanctionner des personnalités qui ont
l'outrecuidance d'aller en russie ou en
crimée bon ben voilà on a ce type de
communication et encore une fois je
envie sur arize ou celle que selon vous
la destination qui ont pose problème
plus peut-être que votre parti on est on
est dans une forme d'idéologie selon
vous en tout cas vu les arguments a
énoncé qui tiennent pas la route
je vous dis ça fait un an que nous
sommes partis là bas on n'a pas été
auditionné
on sait pas sur quelle base ils se sont
fondés effectivement voilà les élections
peut-être permis de ressortir ce dossier
du fond du tiroir et puis on le sait
quoi redonner le faut je souffre voyage
d'observation électorale est ce que vous
avez fait prouver votre bonne foi qu'ils
n'étaient pas fausses et ses voyages
c'est quoi un fou voyage pardonnez moi
il ya des élections en russie c'est une
vraie élection non je sais pas à la
basse et une bonne direction a gelé vu
tout le monde l'a vu même vous les
journalistes ont reporté qu'il ya une
consultation populaire
donc voila moi ce titre j'y vais je vois
que je vois sur place qui a
l'organisation d'élections les images
démontrent aussi voilà ce je vois pas
aujourd'hui pourquoi on nous reproche le
fait d'y être allé si ce n'est que c'est
parce que ça en russie et en crimée et
pardonnez moi encore une fois la crimée
si on veut dû couper l'oxygène mais il
faut le dire mais le peuple le peuple
là-bas existe il y à des instances
haussier représentatif de l'état ça
c'est un fait
et d'y aller pour moi n'est pas un crime
contre l'humanité ce que j'ai déjà dit
mais je pense que c'est vraiment c'est
plutôt politique c'est c'est le fait
qu'on soit aussi du rassemblement
national
voilà on s'est dit allez on va un peu
faire du bruit on encore dire qu'ils
font n'importe quoi
ce qui est totalement faux ça fait un an
que nous sommes allés nous avons été
totalement transparent la déclaration
sont faites on parle de voyage luxueux
mais ce qui est complètement faux
puisque vous voyez bien dans nos
déclarations qu'il n'y a rien de
dispendieux ou de fous donc là encore
une fois c'est la désinformation
orchestrée organisé par certains ont pu
skull du parlement est encore
aujourd'hui vient de recevoir ce jour
une demande de cette fameuse délégation
qui organise des élections pour une
formation va de septembre
d'un côté on nous black list et de
l'autre on nous invite à des formations
un moment donné faut être cohérent soit
en double à kyste et en élimine du
processus
ou alors on fait bien les choses et on
nous invite à ses à ses comédiens
ces observations officielle du parlement
européen
thierry mariani dénonce fallait aussi
visé un des noms ça parlement de plus en
plus totalitaire c'est votre avis aussi
bien oui bah vous le voyez ça veut dire
quoi c'est qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas
l'ena ou où notre mandat pourrait vous
amener c'est à dire que je moi je
demande dans cette liste de pays où j'ai
le droit d'aller 1 est-ce qu'il faut
s'appeler bhl pour aller là où on a
envie d'aller
moi je regrette que le parlement
effectivement applique des règles qui en
fait dénonce c'est à dire aujourd'hui
celle inverse
c'est à dire quoi on nous imposant des
restrictions alors qu'en même temps en
dénoncent des restrictions dans des
états qui ce qui qui qui veulent montrer
qu'ils sont des démocraties dont un
moment donné il faut être cohérent
après voilà s'il ya des siennes liste de
pays où on ne peut pas aller faut nous
le dire faut être précis et en même
temps moi c'est parce je le regrette
parce que notre mandat nous permet
d'aller là où on joue tout le monde
pourrait aller mais qui met par
idéologie ne veulent pas y aller
j'invite les journalistes j'invite tous
les autres députés à y aller à ces
élections et par eux-mêmes voir ce qu'il
s'y passe ils se feront si leur propre
opinion
merci virginie genre en euros des pprn
d'avoir été avec moi en direct sur rt
france